well with me now is uh anthony seldon
biographer john major currently writing
a biography of the first on possibly the
last cameron administration uh welcome
welcome to you indeed uh is it helpful
to bring john major age 72 out of
retirement
well i think if
the evidence was showing that it wasn't
helpful then john major would not be
brought out of retirement so
uh clearly uh a lot of people think that
it is helpful to have him
and he's always been very consistent
about the union and the importance of
keeping scotland in the union and the
risks of uh
scotland leaving so it's something he
feels uh very passionately about i mean
i remember going up scotland with him a
number of times to make speeches as you
say in support of the union it has to be
said it didn't entirely go according to
plan i mean that was a period when the
conservatives were losing mps and
influence in scotland yeah so yes
absolutely so you could say uh that was
that because of john major uh there was
something about him that didn't uh
really pleased the scottish people or
was it despite him
would the trend have been even more
marked if he hadn't uh been raising the
specter of uh the risk of scotland
departing so much so i mean you can you
know we don't know we don't know much
about politics the whole time we think
we know a huge amount like that analysis
there of tweets and it all seems
terribly scientific and graphic but the
truth is i don't think we know very much
i think one of the questions is whether
this notion of
a labor government possibly being hot to
the smp which the conservatives have
been hitting
very hard whether that is going to cut
through what has looked like a sale
mated uh a contest so far well it might
uh it might
and
it's certainly
a very real possibility i mean did we
think perhaps we did when we had the
referendum that that was going to be
scotland put to bed for a generation at
least
uh but you know here we have it it's out
again the issue right at the forefront
of uh this british general election and
the way that it's never been at the
forefront of a british general election
before um and john major coming out now
as somebody who let's remember i mean
everyone you know loves to criticize
john major indeed everyone loves to bash
all former prime ministers don't they uh
because they're stupid and et cetera but
you know john mitchell did get more
votes uh in the 1992 general election
than any uh leader has ever done i mean
amongst people such as the celtic follow
these things closely that is one of the
big debates at the moment are we seeing
a repeat of 1992 do you see
parallels between this election 1992 or
some people say 1910 or yeah people say
1974.
i love this general election because you
can get any pundits up uh looking really
serious and everyone tends to believe
them because
nobody honestly has a clue what's going
to happen in this general election there
are 10 000 people who say that they know
or think they know what's going to
happen but in reality this is such an
unusual general election for the factors
that we've mentioned and uk and uh and
the fact that we have a coalition
government and that's new also so
it's really it's let me ask you this
because you and your team have been as i
say working on a book about david
cameron's government
do you think that
the conservatives david cameron and
george osborne are surprised that it
looks as close as it is at this stage
with barely a fortnight to go well it
it's it's interesting isn't it because
the economy is coming right for them and
businessmen are coming out for them and
the party is rallying together and boris
johnson is rallying uh around it and
there's no sense of a noise is off or a
split conservative party and they've got
john major coming oh yeah
and michael foster
yeah but you know that that you know i
mean that they aren't serious uh players
frankly
um so it is a united party and
many commentators think that the record
of this coalition government with lib
dems fares pretty well compared to but
where are the voters what is it about
this conservative government that
conservative voters don't like and isn't
bringing them out what happened to the
14 million who voted conservative in
1992 where have they gone uh and why are
they not voting for a conservative uh
party now interesting and what is the
answer we will have to find out on may
8th thank you very much indeed